also ich wollte ein bisschen stream
wahrscheinlich geht so ab 8 uhr los
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zusammen mit bereit
willkommen zu minecraft was habt ihr
denn heute für einen plan
heute haben wir einen schönen plan und
zwar werden wir meine lieben freunde
einen kleinen weihnachtsmarkt bauen also
was was ganz persönliches hier so hier
ist noch ein bisschen platz frei wir
werden es auf jeden fall weihnachtsmarkt
nennen
bitte noch mal so wie du das vorhin
gemacht was wir haben gar keine thema am
start aber egal wir haben wir nicht
danach gefragt egal ob schreiben und
aufzunehmen
ja gut wir wollten auf jeden fall so ein
klitzeklein weihnachtsmarkt bauen und
was ich auch sagen wollte ist ich bin
jetzt hier mit switch vertrags auch mal
was ich machen wollte der liebe luca die
luzide zu sorgen wollte heute ein
livestream machen und danke sagen ich
bin auch ein bisschen mit dabei erklärt
er hat sich das selbst beigebracht und
nein also ich hab ich bis sie mit
broadcast & witsch aus einem web designs
gemacht und so und auf tape.tv
schrägstrich kontrakte
ich bin weil ich kann nicht immer
vorzeitig würde gerne mal funktioniert
und dann fangen wir an mit raesfeld
heute ich habe 14 verstanden 14 sinken
ja ich störe wenn ihr das der typ schaut
die folge kommt ja sogar heute wo wir
sie aufnehmen
ob er heute da sitzen gesagt ja es geht
ja noch was mit diesem komischen mit dem
geilen hall zu machen mit den jetzt
genau mit dem holzer wieder wett nein
mit fichten
er wollte dort marketing ich wollte herr
marx weihnachts oder ich wollte einen
weihnachtsmarkt weihnachtsmarkt
beruflich war angesagt beim weihnachts
gegen die miezen nämlich wieder mit marx
auf also das holz kommt einfach nicht
runter kommen kommune zusätzlich von
antoine gut camp ein spa einkommen ein
kurs eine rückkehr in das sind 1 stand
ja das ist ein echt eigentlich fit
da kann man dafür eine chill daran
machen und wir haben auch schon am feld
haben wir auch nicht was angebaut und
dann werden wir so einen riegel haie
shop machen auf dem auf den
weihnachtsmarkt
okay da machen wir auch so ein klein
wenig kennen das werden jetzt machen das
werden wir nach dem letzten machen also
haben wir wollen wir mal live nachfragen
fragen warum
ja
okay machen also ich wollte ein bisschen
stream wahrscheinlich geht so ab 8 uhr
los irgendwann ich kündige das jetzt ja
auch nicht so groß an mit irgendeinem
extra video noch dafür ich poste dass da
nur auf twitter der wiener setzten
kurzem bei und wir werden also ein
bisschen mehr kraft free talk und der
marke jahr fragen ich habe gerade erst
mal getötet und du kannst du kannst du
ja im retreat nennen kommt bestimmt
viele fragen nee ich bereue es hier
weiter
wir sind gerade spitzen dabei ja wir
machen also richtig schönen großen
weihnachtsbaumes reicher und meiner frau
auch noch ein bisschen weiter daran
auf jeden fall und dann wird das super
geil und im leitstand sich ein bisschen
komisch aus war das ein anderes holz ist
aber vielleicht auch ganz cool wäre das
für tisch und es wird er wird
unterschiedlich dem einstand an
schön sieht gar nicht aus wie diner oder
ich habe dann einfach ich habe mir
einfach improvisiert so wie ich den ball
ich bin einer der krassesten in diesem
game hier älter ich werde ganz schön
wenn wir hier oben noch so was drauf
machen
jetzt gibt aber auch schon hier auf
anderes level das sieht sehr schön aus
wir können die auf einen fernseher wie
macht man braun stand nicht
wir könnten jene tür hinsetzen und ich
hab ne bessere die wir können fein türen
weiter vorne dran machen das sieht schön
aus spitze
in dich schön ab was du na ja doch das
zaun tönen machen oder so funktioniert
es doch von sexy machen die dahin wird
improvisiert noch ein bisschen geschockt
wie guck mal wie schön ist aussieht
jetzt guck mal
ja das macht es auch nach mache wie hast
du das so hingekriegt doherr mit hexen
ein schaf das könnte auch weitere
aktionen bei dir machen wird die
abdeckung in den weihnachts noch ganz
groß geschrieben
du hast bestimmt ein schulfach boten
diese sprache lernen
oder kommen die fragen reinalter habt
ihr vorsätze fürs neue jahr ist es nicht
so fries aber so bisschen silvester wir
machen nämlich semesterprojekt das hängt
am 31 an und endet am 31 wir machen
silvester livestream werden so weil wir
haben kein leben und wollen selbst nicht
feiern
ich kann nicht ruhig dreikampf
dieser kampf siegel an kraft
wie heißen noch mal sowieso steinbeck
oder so
also haben wir vorsichtig dessen herlitz
das ist ja das ist der spitzenstadt den
weg was so siehst du wieder gar nicht so
scheiße auch wenn du dann hier oben
dunkles holz so dunkle holz labs weil
machst jetzt habe ich mal schön aus an
der stelle auf der meinungsseite zum 1
so habe ich dann da sind ins treffen
ich weiß nicht ich weiß ich glaub was du
meinst weils eure daten der rücken ein
schild ich war heute auch das ist aber
so ein großes loch
da kocht dritten arm noch 33 aber so ist
sehr schön was wir machen also haben wir
vor setzt schalten richtig tacke aus
alter ich will mehr wie kompost einem
neuen jahr
wie doof die luft das aussieht wie kann
man das machen lässt sich durch macht
doch noch mal dunkles holz darunter
mache einfach luca com
hierhin
wir müssen jetzt diesen weihnachtsmarkt
er muss in den nächsten folgen fertig
werden deswegen jetzt in ordnung
sag mal luca
suchen wir noch nach dem thema oder die
welche vorsätze mein vorletzte sehen
also ich würde gerne ein bisschen mehr
fleisch so für schule und sowas zeigen
und mehr aufbringen besser gesagt und
dann vielleicht noch ein bisschen
professioneller bisschen ernster youtube
angehen und so was aber insgesamt bin
ich schon ganz ihnen also was ich so für
elemente habe in meinem lebensplan für
elemente element element wasser feuer
luft und trifft pixel
aber schneewittchen fresse werden ich
hoffe es geht ihm gut
ich wollte nämlich grad diesen coolen
weg machen so ein bisschen runter dass
der unterkante von denen ein honorar
macht mal so ein schild so fritzsche
kartoffeln oder sowas frischen kaffee
ja man müsste was das wissen sonst
fertigern in dem weihnachtsmarkt
okay wir schreiben das texture pack um
so das zeigt dass das gebrannte mandeln
sind stadt ihr schreiben ist um vor
allem beschreiben die grafik die die
texturen sowieso da steht dann drin so
eine art
ich mache mit all meinen weg da wird wir
brauchen noch ein bisschen remmel
du machst travel
ich kaufe dir jetzt bin ich schon da
denn herr goppel kim wildes tier fall
schön design autos katar fest
bratkartoffeln gebracht
diesen verbrannt die barriere in dem
business hat der geniale seht ihr was
man hier kommt auf der seite der
nächsten jahr auf jeden fall mehr also
ich habe mich in mein mann vor vorsatz
fürs nächste jahr ist dass ich auf jeden
fall auch mehr für die uni mache und
dass sich youtube ausmisten so weit
zurzeit ist halt so ich denke mir so
abends um zehn uhr kaum noch ein zwei
runden fifa aber diese zeit hätte man
doch einfach in noch lernen oder
irgendwas für die uni tun investieren
können deswegen denke ich mir so geht
auf jeden fall noch was genau macht
nebenbei beruf von mir ein bisschen das
man produktiver wird produktivität
einfach jetzt gemacht hast du bist ja
für die marke leistet ich hab ein stand
gebaut und praktische kartoffeln keinen
gescheiten seinen favoriten
statt der als verbrannte mandeln und
eine gescheite man schaut wie wie süß
dass hier vor sich hin schmökert hier
die warte ich muss noch ein schreiben
was es ist schau mal wie sie sich den
weg gemacht
dieser baum weg sofort mutig am steins
verbranntem anderen ende
lasst mich sprache und sprachrohr für
dein wort ist auch dynamisch auch drin
nächste frage ich wollte weg hier ein
bisschen baum kommt da bin ich total
latif drin da hier auch eine frage wie
hat er lud die auf den display von
tschad reagiert keine ahnung
eigentlich habe ich hier österreichs
geschrieben hat
geschickt da war ja nicht nüchtern ist
aller lustigste video was du jemals
gemacht hat weil das wurde nicht ganz
nicht mehr gespielt dass er das letzte
mal angeschaut
hast du das palais und lidl nicht
gesehen das hat stürmer zusammen
aber die folge zu ende in der nächsten
folge geht es beim adh weiter die kommt
auch noch heute auf seinem kanal also
heute ist der neunte wenn ihr das seht
und da kommt auch eine folge bei max
oder ist sogar schon online vielleicht
da bauen wir dann aus dem markt weiter
hier in mandls seite denn märz dem acker
machen bei nacht ein markt ist das da
könnte doch weiter schauen wir doch
machen wir den weihnachtsmarkt wissen
fertig und natürlich sagen sie wir uns
dort wieder beziehungsweise morgen in
der nächsten folge bei mir auf dem kanal
und